white Dallas police officer is free on
bond this morning after being charged
with manslaughter in a bizarre shooting
that left a black man dead inside his
own home off-duty police officer Amber
Geiger is accused of killing both Amjad
the officer allegedly told investigators
she mistook his apartment for her own
and shot and killed him after she went
inside Omar Villafranca is at the Dallas
apartment complex
Omar good morning good morning the Texas
Rangers have taken over this
investigation but there are still a lot
of questions like what exactly happened
on the fourth floor of this apartment
complex why did a Sheriff's Department
almost 30 miles away arrest her when she
lives two blocks from Dallas Police
Headquarters and why did it take almost
three days until she was arrested
amateur video captured late last week
appears to show the moments after an
off-duty Dallas police officer allegedly
shot and killed 26 year-old both am john
you would be arrested if we went to the
wrong apartment and blow a hole in a
person's chest killing them
j'onn family attorneys and local
politicians railed against the Dallas
Police Department for failing to make a
timely arrest in the case to make
certain that we're sure in Texas no
separate standard as it relates to
police officers when they commit these
types of crimes Dallas Police say
officer amber Geiger who has been with
the Department for four years told them
she mistakenly entered John's apartment
after her shift thinking it was her own
she was still in uniform when she
encountered mr. Gean in the apartment at
some point she fired her weapon striking
the victim details about what happened
directly before the shooting remain
unclear
he was my pride and my joy but John's
family members continue to search for
answers there are times when you feel
like giving up I could not give up
because of both
I'm right now in his death
I can never give up
officer Geiger is now on paid
administrative leave the Dallas County
District Attorney plans to have a press
conference later on this morning and
hopefully we'll learn some more answers
Vlad
Omar thank you very much that's a
disturbing story